prenez un moment et penser à la plus
belle chose que vous ayez jamais vu de
vos propres yeux
cette vision ne vous apporte-t-elle pas
un sentiment de joie de paix et
d'émerveillement maintenant que
ressentiriez vous si vous perdiez la
vision pour beaucoup de gens la vision
et leur sens le plus important au dessus
de l'ouïe de l'odorat et du goût parfois
le sens visuel peut même l'emporter sur
d'autres sens
comme on le voit dans l'illusion de la
main en caoutchouc ou de la main en cire
dans cette étude
notre propre main droite est cachée hors
de vue tandis qu'une reproduction très
réaliste et posé sur la table à côté de
notre main gauche les deux mains droites
la vraie et la fosse faune et flore et
en même temps dans ces conditions le
cerveau se fiait ce qu'ils voient plutôt
qu'est ce qu'il ressent et commence à
croire que cette main fabriqués chez
madame tussauds est vraiment connecté à
notre corps cette sensation est si
réelle que lorsqu un stimulus douloureux
inattendus tels qu un poignard est
amenée sur la main artificielle
nous allons sursauter de douleur et de
surprises même s'il ne s'est rien
produit
car le cerveau en est venu à voir celle
ci comme notre propre main croyez-moi ça
fonctionne chez certaines personnes des
mutations génétiques conduisent à un
ensemble de maladies familiale connue
sous le nom collectif de maladie
héréditaire de la rétine
ce regroupement de maladies causées par
plus de 270 mutation identifiée à date
inclut les rétinites pigmentaires et
continue de croître au fur et à mesure
de l'identification de nouveaux gènes
cause at her dans ces cas les
person nes avec une fonction anormales
de leurs rétines qui sont les cellules
délicate au fond de l'oeil qui capte la
lumière et transmettre l'information
visuelle vers le cerveau ici voyez
l'image qui représente une rétine dont
la surface semble tapissée par une fine
toile d'araignée ceci est une
représentation classique de la rétinite
pigmentaire ainsi que des changements de
pigmentation qui donnent leur nom à la
maladie cette image est tout aussi belle
qu'elle est dévastatrice
car chez ces gens là vision nocturne ne
se développent pas normalement où elle
peut s'éclipser au fur et à mesure d'une
dégénérescence pré programmés jusqu'à
aller vers une noirceur totale
cela peut se produire pendant l'enfance
ou plus tard dans la vie adulte
imaginez à quel point cela peut changer
une vie
quand on vous annonce soudainement que
votre vision s'est détériorée à un tel
point que vous ne pouvez plus conduire
étant devenu trop dangereux sur les
routes par manque de vision périphérique
vous ne pouvez plus travailler dans le
même domaine qu'avant ou même cette
maladie peut vous dérobez de la
possibilité de voir le visage de vos
proches et de vos enfants
au fil des années cela doit être un
sentiment effrayant de voir sa vision
renfermé petit à petit sur soi et de se
sentir impuissant de faire quoi que ce
soit pour l'arrêter car cette condition
était considérée incurable ce n'est plus
le cas car maintenant il ya un espoir de
changement
et aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
deux approches de traitement
la prothèse rétinienne et la thérapie
génique dans lequel chaque approche
cible une extrémité du spectre de la
maladie
je me sens privilégié d'être impliqué en
tant qu'hôpital mot logist est
chirurgienne de la rétine est de pouvoir
offrir ces traitements révolutionnaires
ainsi que la promesse qu'elle tienne
pour des thérapies
futur dans la phase tardive
une fois que la maladie est avancé un
stade avancé
la prod et rétiniennes peut donner une
nouvelle dimension à la vision cet
appareil connu populairement sous le nom
de l' oeil bionique fonctionne en
capturant l'environnement autour de nous
à l'aide d'une petite caméra montée sur
une paire de lunettes que l'utilisateur
porte le système transforme ces images
en stimulation électrique qui sont
transmises par les électrodes au niveau
de la puce implantée au niveau de la
rétine
cette puce stimule les cellules
rétiniennes vivant restantes et relaie
le message à travers le nerf optique
vers le cerveau c'est la saur en images
pixels et de contours clairs et sombre
en mouvement ici vous voyez à gauche
madame sandra cassel l'une des premières
patientes opérées ici au québec et au
canada par mon collègue dr flavio
resende et moi même elle porte des
lunettes bien chic qui semble sortir de
chez ray ban ou au clic mais en fait ce
sont des lunettes spéciales qui sont
appareillés à l'implant à l'intérieur de
son oeil dans un exemple où la science
imite l'art et peut-être surpasse l'art
ce qui est étonnant c'est que notre
cerveau est capable de déchiffrer ces
pixels et apprendre à les interpréter
à quel point est ce que notre cerveau et
il puissant laissez-moi vous partagez un
exemple comme vous le savez peut-être
l'oeil fonctionne sur le même principe
optique qu'une caméra et le monde autour
de nous est en fait répéter à l'envers
sur la rétine s'est pas cependant pas
révolution nous sommes habitués à voir
ces images à l'endroit alors maintenant
imaginez que vous partiez une paire de
lunettes spéciales qui inverse
votre vision du monde que se
passerait-il si comme moi vous avez des
nausées simplement à la pensée d'aller
sur des montagnes russes à la ronde
eh bien vous avez de la chance car le
chercheur georges tron a déjà fait cette
expérience pour nous il n'ya plus de 100
ans il a porté des lunettes spéciales
inverseur sur un casque à temps plein
même lorsqu'il dort mais pensez vous
qu'ils s'y est habitué et combien de
temps at il fallu quelques jours
quelques semaines ou jamais bien qu'il
ait eu à mal des transports terrible
initialement après six jours il
commençait déjà à s'y habituer et à
revoir le monde autour de lui à
l'endroit cela ne fait que démontrer à
quel point notre cerveau et notre cortex
visuel sont puissants et qu'il peut
s'adapter à n'importe quel défi visuel
lancé par notre environnement
de la même manière après une prothèse
rétinienne les patients ne retrouve pas
la vie d'avant cependant la mémoire de
ce que voir signifie leur permet de
développer une nouvelle vision
électronique
si bien qu'ils sont capables de la corée
dans des tâches visuels tels que le tir
à l'arc ou même pourrait apprendre à
skier à l'autre bout du spectre
nous avons des patients souvent des
enfants chez qui on diagnostique une
maladie héréditaire de la rétine et qui
commencent tout juste à perdre la vision
la thérapie génique et la proche la plus
adaptée dans cette situation dans ce
traitement
le gène en faute et remplacée par une
copie fonctionnelle du bon gène qui est
introduit de manière chirurgicale au
niveau de la rétine
tout comme introduire un rouage manquant
dans un système qui s'était arrêté ceci
permettra aux cycles visuels de
fonctionner à nouveau
la thérapie génique diffère de la
prothèse rétiniennes en ce que le
traitement et la maladie sont très
spécifiques
l'un pour l'autre et une thérapie
génique ne peut corriger qu'une seule
mutation exact tout comme un ensemble de
serrures et de clés le cheminement
scientifique
et amener vers ce succès a commencé il
ya plus de vingt ans avec
l'identification du gène rpe65 dont la
mutation mène à un type de rétinite
pigmentaire appelé l'amaurose
congénitale de leber
par la suite un modèle animal de la
maladie a été identifiée chez la race de
chien brière qui développe une cécité
progressive de façon naturelle lorsque
leur gène rpe65 est défectueux après des
essais cliniques
le produit génique a été développé et
implanté au niveau du chien briard avec
des résultats encourageants de regain
visuel il a fallu plusieurs voyages sur
la colline du capitole à washington par
lancelot l'un des premiers sujets de la
thérapie génique pour faire reconnaître
et approuvé des essais cliniques sur
l'être humain
de nos jours grâce à la contribution de
ses premiers modèles animaux et par la
suite des sujets humains sur plus de dix
ans la thérapie génique est devenu
publiquement approuvé comme norme de
traitement standard ici au québec et au
canada pour la toute première fois au
lieu de gérer uniquement les symptômes
de la maladie
ce traitement peut cibler directement la
cause de la perte de vision profonde et
maintenant lancer nos est reconnu comme
aro international dans le domaine de la
médecine
sachez qu'il a pris une belle retraite
bien méritée en temps voulu et a
pleinement profité de ses jours en
faisant bon usage de sa vision en jouant
dehors et en lisant à loisir des revues
scientifiques pour illustrer la
différence visuelle et fonctionnelle
chez une jeune patiente implanté par
thérapie génique
voici deux vidéos prises un avant et
l'autre après le traitement
à un an d'intervalle dans cette tâche
la jeune patiente doit naviguer à
labyrinthes et terminé le parcours en
moins de trois minutes
en suivant les flèches ici à gauche
avant le traitement on voit qu'elle
hésite qu'elle se heurte aux obstacles
qu'il échoue dans sa mission dès le
début tandis qu'à droite après le
traitement
on voit toute la différence elle
s'avance avec confiance avec aisance et
termine le parcours en une vingtaine de
secondes ce qui démontre les faits
évidents et durable du traitement en fin
de présentation
je laisse la parole aux jeunes patients
qui ont déjà bénéficié de ce traitement
et qui décrivent l'expérience dans leurs
propres mots jack ici à gauche
un jeune adolescent au sourire rayonnant
s'étonne que c'est comme si une lumière
s'est allumée est clair tout dans sa vie
quid ici au milieu un petit garçon au
sourire timide qui a pris cette photo
lors de son dernier anniversaire
quelques jours avant sa chirurgie peut
maintenant bien voir au tableau même
quand il est assis tout au fond de sa
classe et dans les mots de sam ici à
droite un petit montréal et est le
premier patient canadien à avoir reçu le
traitement par thérapie génique il
s'exclame je peux enfin voir les étoiles
nous ne pouvons pas empêcher aux
mutations génétiques qui affecte la vue
de se manifester dans la nature mais
avec une détection précoce avec des
tests génétiques nous pouvons réécrire
l'évolution de la maladie en rossant la
vision qu'il subsiste grâce à la
prothèse rétiniennes ou en l'améliorant
grâce à la thérapie génique combinée à
la puissance de la neuroplasticité de
notre système visuel
les gens ne retrouve pas la vision du
passé
toutefois ils peuvent en effet
réapprendre à voir avec la vision du
futur comme ils n'ont jamais vu
auparavant
merci
[Applaudissements]